if I was watching this video I'd
probably want to know the answers
straight away so one double it to deal
with whatever you have three do it
consistently what's going on guys my
name is David homage and welcome back to
the channel if you're new here and have
absolutely no idea who I am well like I
said my name is David Tomich I'm a
masters of architecture graduate and
I've done a lot in my life so far
without naming absolutely everything
I've done I've run a multinational
company I've started multiple online
businesses I've written an e-book I've
graduated with a master's degree in
architecture
I've worked full time I've worked for
myself I have done I think you can
probably think of I've probably tried it
and that's kind of where it led me to
the YouTube pathway and the YouTube
ideology for career so right now in 2020
I've been on YouTube for about 17 months
I started on the 11th of February 2019
and since that video my videos have
progressed significantly they're still
not perfect they're still not great but
they are better and that takes me to my
very first point should you start a
YouTube channel the answer like I said
is very simple the answer is yes because
if you're even just watching this video
it means you're contemplating it in the
back of your mind and thinking is this a
good idea should I do this is it a waste
of time is it too late I thought the
same thing for so many years I can
recall back in 2015 back in 2010
thinking to myself should I start is it
too late ah it's probably too late no
point and those years just kept going on
and on and on and I kept having the same
thought now I don't know if you've had
these thoughts before if this is the
first time you're thinking about it but
either way you really need to make the
leap and just start if you've decided
and I'm hoping you have by now to make a
youtube channel what is it that you need
to get started well I had the liberty of
having a bit of equipment to start with
because like I said
a million and one things in my life so
far so I already had a whole bunch of
videography equipment ready to go but
the funny thing was my career before was
kind of focused on photography and not
videography so the camera I had was kind
of garbage for video if you go back to
my very first video you'll be able to
tell it was out of focus the sound was
horrible the lighting was terrible and
overall it was a mediocre video I was
very awkward on camera I had no idea how
to actually talk to a camera or would
even look most the time I was looking
down onto the side or not actually
acknowledging that somebody like
yourself would be watching this video
right now whatever time of day or night
it is so to start it's very simple if
you have a smartphone doesn't matter
what it is use that if you have a camera
use that it genuinely doesn't need to be
a whole set up like I have in here okay
so what if you don't have a smartphone
what if you don't have a camera what if
you have absolutely nothing to record on
can you borrow it can you find a friend
that has it can you ask somebody in your
school to help you out can you make it a
project and potentially get your school
to loan you the equipment there is
always and I'm hoping always some sort
of solution for you to get started if
you can't afford the technology the
lighting the microphone the background
keep it simple use a blank white wall
and that's that's it somebody I do
follow on YouTube quite often is Dave 2d
his background setup and whole studio
setup is so simple one desk two lights
in the background that's it where is
this I've seen other youtubers that
aren't even there they're literally one
blank white wall it doesn't need to be
fancy is what I'm trying to get to you
guys if you have the ability to start
doesn't matter how you do it use a
window use a light source use anything
you can
improve the quality now that brings me
to point two of this video and it's be
consistent being consistent on YouTube
is what gets you there very slowly I'm
not huge on YouTube I don't make a
million dollars a month I will go
through what I make on YouTube a little
bit later in this video so stay tuned if
you're interested I upload once a week
every week consistently on a Monday
night for you this might be on a Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday it doesn't
matter in my opinion I believe it is
good to consistently upload I genuinely
try and do it once a week because that's
all the time I have right now to
dedicate to YouTube but you you might
think that you have enough time to do
two videos a month or two videos a week
it doesn't really matter as long as
you're consistent now the quality is
probably going to be pretty bad for the
first 10 20 30 100 videos some of the
quality of my videos is still pretty
average but the point is being
consistent and having it uploaded
consistently the quality will get better
as you get more comfortable as you learn
to master your craft as you figure out
that if you turn the light a little bit
brighter or if you move it further away
or if you can somehow get somebody to
stand behind the camera and tell you
that it's not looking too good
push that that way move this this way
sit further back maybe come forward that
will help the video these are just the
little things that over time you will
master and your videos will get better
more and more people will start watching
and eventually you will grow a channel
it won't happen overnight it definitely
won't happen in a month and it more than
likely won't happen in 12 months but if
you consistent it will continue to grow
so what do you talk about on YouTube or
try find something that you're
passionate about and there's two ways to
go about this you can a find something
you're passionate about and continuously
talk about it and educate people on it
or be you can find something you're
passionate about and follow trends now
the reason I bring this up is because
the way you do either of these two is
the way you want
is a ssin and your income is actually
going to be directly affected so let me
read some stats to you guys on the first
day I monetized my channel it was on the
22nd of October 2019 that means it took
me eight months to go from zero to one
thousand subscribers and monetize my
channel on that very first day that it
was monetized I made a whole one dollar
and 23 cents
huge game changing and I quit my job I
can't give up I can just be a youtube
sensation fantastic as the months
progressed then I continued to bring out
more and more content that continued to
go up and slowly go back down eventually
on most days I'd make anywhere from one
to five dollars not a big deal but
that's one to five dollars I wasn't
making elsewhere as the channel
continued to grow and more and more
people started to subscribe and watch it
started to increase exponentially at one
point I reached 17 dollars and ninety
three cents in one day again
groundbreaking and I so crazy but it
didn't matter that doesn't matter to me
the monetization doesn't matter the fact
that it's growing consistently and going
up and up and up means something it
means people are starting to engage with
the content and genuinely enjoy it this
brings me back to my previous point
there's two ways of making content I try
and make content that is continuously
going to be watched I try and make
content that doesn't matter if it's 2019
2020 like it is now or 2025 five years
in the future I'm hoping that the
content I make people are still going to
be able to resonate with yes most of my
videos a tech focused and tech goes out
of date pretty quickly but that doesn't
mean people stop watching it and stop
looking for reviews
just because you've sold it your
three-year-old phone it doesn't mean
somebody else isn't buying that
three-year-old a new phone let me give
you a real world example I have two
videos that have done exceptionally well
my one video which was educating people
about e-commerce it was called week's
verse Squarespace for Shopify it makes
me about 38% of my monthly revenue and
38% of my
total revenue so far on YouTube that's a
video I consider to be a very
educational very structural video that
doesn't change over time in the next
five years I still predict people will
be looking at getting into e-commerce
and learning how to sell products
internationally nationally to people
they don't know to people they do know
and what platforms are used it does
consistently well every month it makes
me roughly the same amount of money
continuously it goes up and down a
little bit but not too much
now another video I made was very
situational inappropriate it was a video
at the height of the Cova 19 pandemic
when it all started and everybody in the
world went home it's a video comparing
WebEx zoom and Skype it is something
that was at the height and at the tip of
everybody's tongue it was something that
everybody searched for and what you can
see is that I had a huge spike in the
income from that video at the start but
now that people are going back to work
around the world and we aren't using
these video communication tools as much
anymore my revenue has just plummeted
from that video and more than likely in
a few years time I'm never gonna see any
more income from that video now it's sad
that most of my income or 50% of it
comes from two videos and one of them
being something that's probably going to
die very quickly but that's the way
YouTube works
you're gonna upload hundreds and
hundreds of hundreds of videos and maybe
ten of those thousands are going to be
good maybe one but all it takes is one
and that's why consistency is the key to
this whole video it's about posting
consistently and making sure that that
one at least has the chance of becoming
something phenomenal so like I said at
the start of the video guys do it do it
now do it with whatever you have and do
it consistently eventually your channel
will grow and you will make something
out of this passion that you have anyway
that's all I have for you today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did smash
that subscribe button
20:20 style and as always I see you next